an é mais obrigado até pelo convite por
estar capas falar de um tema que o meu
pai só não teme a página dos últimos
anos e antes de mais por exemplo de 30
segundos ou malta está muito focado aqui
no relógio de 30 segundos vou mudar
aquilo a única palavra que trago hoje
provou seja ea palavra é basta basta
dizermos é de nos perguntar a opinião de
quatro em quatro anos
basta z nos pedirem opinião é sobre uns
uns programas políticos que depois nunca
são bem executados hoje em dia nós
queremos e eu quero e eu exijo ser
ouvido mais freqüentemente será ouvido e
e as minhas demandas serem escutadas
- algumas delas aquelas que tiverem
maior consenso
isso é a diferença entre democracia
aposentada diva que é aquilo que nós
todos estamos habituados e democracia é
a e democracia participativa e esse é o
tema que vai encarar falar hoje
democracia participativa algo do cidadão
está mais envolvido no vi havia decisão
dos problemas que existem
não é algo contra a democracia
participativa e representativa não é
pelo contrário é complementar
criamos mais envolvência e os cidadãos
antes mais parte da sociedade democracia
eu considero essa a democracia o próximo
passo que tentamos muito bem aqui falar
democracia temos que falar ver direitos
humanos direitos humanos começou e o
primeiro registo escrito é ver persia
há muitos muitos anos atrás mas eu
também não era muito perfeita e portanto
andré daquilo que escrevi nem sempre
fazia
mais tarde os gregos também
sistematizaram inspiraram os persas
evoluíram e sinalizaram para resolver
conflitos sociais
uma coisa que chamaram democracia o
cidadão
'ser valer a sua opinião de forma igual
vamos pôr mais uma vez entre aspas de
forma igual - para as mulheres e para os
cravos
ok é portanto não há sistemas perfeitos
não vamos apresentar aqui não vou falar
um sistema perfeito
vamos falar de uma pequena parte de uma
metodologia dó democracia participativa
chamada orçamento participativo muitos
de vós provavelmente já ouviram falar
mas vamos começar o início toda a gente
já falou se portanto vamos também falar
de mim há 30 anos atrás
mais coisa menos coisa eu estava neste
jardim
provavelmente daqui o banco em oliveira
de frades é estava com os meus pais lá
que os flocos ou vemos assuntos pessoais
e já não sei porque estava a conversar
com desconhecidos
e o fez uma daquelas perguntas que se
fazem os jovens que estavam na resposta
dizer não que é costas porque eu não ia
o ao fim de meia hora lá me convenceu de
que política não meus políticos política
é e cidadãos a trabalhar em prol dos
cidadãos trabalhar para prol do bem
comum ea sereia ficou comigo ficou
comigo e vou eu ia o homem vira teve um
percurso sá em termos associativos do
clube de coração bastante preenchido
também estive ligada à ipss e ainda
estou como na assembleia geral de uma é
o meu percurso profissional vou me
afundar várias empresas e em várias
delas nomeadamente onde estou agora
conseguir sempre pensar numa coisa que é
como é que nós conseguimos criar usar o
impacto para o cidadão
e foi isso que num momento de 15 em 2007
admira
sonhamos com um desafio temos o maior
concelho do país apenas com 26 mil
pessoas
queremos fazer democracia participativa
uma coisa que eu chamava orçamento
participativo não fazia a mínima ideia
do que era na altura e ao de cima com a
minha área com o número pessoas que eu
tenho isso tem que ser uma plataforma na
internet
tem que ser algo que me permita chegar a
toda a gente ser inclusivo
agora vai
v lançamos para perceber o que é que é
para que os que não sabem orçamento
participativo uma instituição na maioria
autarquias mas pode ser o governo
portugal também fez isso em o cidadão a
é um carro um terminal no orçamento os
tiros não são idéias discutidas e
esquecida imputando importante elas são
executadas
ok isso tem várias fases tem vários
processos a ao processo decisão eo
processo de acompanhamento mas acima de
tudo sempre envolvendo muitos cidadãos
ora bem nós em portugal estamos a
trabalhar com mais 50 autarquias fazem
hoje o orçamento participativo
olhamos também para fora a nível mundial
já existem mais de 3 mil casos estamos a
trabalhar com espanha
você tem a conquista ela com várias
cidades na escócia e mais recentemente
com os estados unidos
tudo casos diferentes contextos
diferentes muitos dias de implementação
de três mas as mesmas regras do cidadão
para o cidadão com o cidadão
vamos falar alguns daqueles que são os
nossos maiores orgulhos 35 milhões de
euros
desde 2007 são 35 milhões de euros de
dinheiro público seguir pelos cidadãos
são 36 por cento da população a estreia
que participou no processo do ano
passado são no processo do ano passado
em angra 80% das pessoas que
participaram não tenham voltavam das
autárquicas 2011
estamos a chegar a posições que não
estão não fazem parte do sistema não
participam porque já não acreditam e não
estamos a conseguir mas vou fazer voltar
a acreditar mas eles todos têm dúvidas
nesse processo desde logo político o
político está sem beber a cerveja e
hinos nas mãos dias normais de orçamento
participativo participação e meio por
cento um por cento quando chega aos
internautas já está a dar o salto
ora aí nós cá em portugal estamos a
conseguir chegar a 10 15% com muito
qualidade e saia chegou a 36 isso pra
pro político isto cansa estava o
dinheiro está a ser poder estar ser em
troca
para o técnico é um processo altamente
pedagógico para o técnico da autarquia
da instituição inicia um contacto e
ético cidadão vai aprender com
conhecimento que o cidadão time povos
partilhar podem ensinar argumentos a
construções que tem e juntos
criativamente é rezar em soluções para o
cidadão óbvio a dúvida é sempre o mesmo
o eta que vai implementar não não
acredito nisto e eu já ouvi isto em todo
o arco foi bem ó orçamento participativo
nenhuma das primeiras regras é sim o
político tem que implementar e portanto
nós nas nossas funções não temos sempre
ferramentas monitorização para que isso
seja possível acompanhar ao longo destes
anos temos tem muitos desafios
desde logo é simples tirar toda a gente
tem que poder votar é que é o que gosta
de internet o que gosto do mapa gosta de
sms
isso eu não gosto nada nem sequer votar
em papel e tivemos que nas nossas
funções do ter e acautelar todas essas
funções ao mesmo tempo sempre aquela
dúvida mas isso é internet e malta vai
lá e vai alterar para bem tivemos criará
mecanismos anti fraude
quando ficamos e fomos lá para fora
os desafios foram diferentes chegamos a
países onde não havia tirava não há
registo de cidadãos olha aí como é que
nós conseguimos conquistar controlar que
a sida não só faltou uma vez maior de
cidadãos temos aqui tivemos inventar
coisas para resolver todos esses
problemas
tivemos também construir solução que
fosse motim e nós vamos falar em
chinatown nos nova york em inglês e aos
não nos ouvem não participam
temos que ter os pontos formas na língua
nativa dessas comunidades
ela vai falar na prática alguns projetos
muito rapidamente nos orgulho imenso
- os jovens chegaram alvará uma
assembléia decisão
de propostas tenha 120 pessoas na sala e
alguns conseguiram convencer as pessoas
com o projeto de deus era melhor na
decisão final mil 108 votos que
conseguiram 50 mil euros para um
projecto vocacionado para jovens em
guimarães no orçamento participativo
escolar pessoas e alunos sentiram que a
minha forma de se deslocar para a escola
de bicicleta e compraram bicicletas ea
captura as bicicletas e mais houvesse
mais crianças iam todos os dias de
bicicleta para a escola em valongo que
perto os jovens decidiram criar uma sala
específica para outros jovens com um
portador de deficiência
criaram uma final as noções muitos deus
eu próprio também não sabia o que era e
fui perceber e é algo fantástico sá
todos os dias para melhorar a qualidade
de vida desses jovens em agra e agora
que destruiu uma apresentação toda mas
pronto em agra surgimento conhecida com
os seus guarda-chuvas conseguiu a
comunidade em dois anos consecutivos
quem a 50 mil euros mais 50 mil euros
para a construção do parque botânico
magnólias e mais recentemente agora
estando conseguiu mais 200 mil euros no
orçamento participativo na final
melhor que isso isso foi tudo conseguido
por uma comunidade cigana do vau domingo
uma comunidade muitas vezes colocar na
parte e com excesso conseguiu tornar-se
inclusiva dentro da sociedade e criar
algo para deixar o futuro ao que vai
provavelmente ser uma marca maior do que
provavelmente os guarda-chuvas trazer
gente e é que proíbe a exposição charter
chineses tirar fotografias que agora o
em tirar fotografias aos chapéus vão
poder usufruir de um grande parque de
máquinas alejo mas não só cai portugal
na escócia fizeram um primeiro orçamento
participativo mundial usando a nossa
plataforma para um tema tão complicado
mesmo
uma fria em santiago compostela
cidadania dos que os perceber enquanto
externo o maior número de votos foi para
projetos para as festas da cidade ou
seja que beneficiam toda a comunidade e
não apenas a sua o seu bairro
o único metro nós temos ao longo do
tempo ajudado muitas autarquias com
plataformas de ocorrências
a eni experiências a nível nacional com
plataforma windows vai ouvir falar do
fox de partilha de decisão e de alerta
sobre onde é k fogos etc
há muitos mecanismos mas acima de tudo
nós temos é que participaram esta é o
nosso grande desafio em termos de
oportunidade neste momento nós temos os
políticos sensibilizados prestaria mas
nós precisamos de participar
nós temos a capacidade de influenciar
nas decisões
uma amiga minha que às vezes é o volume
dizia nós em orçamento participativo
conseguimos ser super heróis
conseguimos ajudar a mudar o mundo sendo
super heróis e essa é aquilo que eu
entendo que é o nosso momento é este o
momento o senhor seus super heróis e
esse é o momento que nós temos para
dizer eu quero ajudar a mudar o mundo
para tal nós só temos que dizer sem
basta
e eu quero participar eu espero que
todos nós quando a zona orçamentos
participativos nas vossas regiões ou
outro tipo de ações façam exatamente
isso tem passo que estar presente dizer
e eu estou aqui e eu quero participar
muito obrigado
[Música]
[Aplausos]